if you go in and look at the sands it's
in Los Angeles 1940 ish there's an event
that takes place there will they
actually shoot 1,400 rounds at this
thing up in the sky oh my people were
actually killed on the ground because of
the shrapnel that came down hit on the
ground but people's homes were hit this
was during the Japanese war and so they
they assumed that this was the Japanese
that were coming here but they shot this
thing there's lights on it they shot it
for I don't know well over an hour I
never dropped it
so you know it's called I want to say
it's called the attack in LA or I can't
think of the name of it now but it was a
real event that took place over LA were
they actually shot what year I want to
say during this was during the Japanese
works they thought the Japanese okay and
they never knew what it was never knew
what it was never came out and said they
got videos you know pictures of it they
they every V every they had these
positions that were set up with all
these different lights so that if you
came as a bomber they could put the
lights on you know at night you can see
where the guy was the bombers fly real
high and they fly real slow and so they
would use these big lights well they've
got every light turned on on this thing
and it's lit up you can see something in
the center but no one's willing to say
it's a UFO they're not willing to say
it's a spacecraft of any sort
they just keep acting like well we'd
really don't know what it is I'm like if
you're shot at it for an hour and didn't
knock it out of the sky and it
disappeared later I would say it's
probably an extraterrestrial of some
sort it's obviously not from this planet
because we've not any being able to
shoot it down like that but I think
we're just a warring community anyway we
were again if go back and look at the
gods if you look at the Greeks and how
they wrestled everything was based on
your physical strength and make it being
a better person you know is that alive
and well today sure it is I mean look at
football and hockey we look at the
strongman contests and look at what men
do to be men today politics it's all
about power yeah you know about power so
and how do you how do you emulate that
power what do you like about it some
people like it because they it's money
other guys like it because it's a
position of authority
you know you put those two together
especially if whatever technologies you
could get from Annie a UFO you would
want to be able to use to your best
military right you know yes that's
another thing Bob Lazar talked about was
that in like in areas forward they were
studying like the propulsion of these
spacecraft and how they worked you know
they kept everything part
compartmentalized every different person
that was working on a different part of
one of those crafts they kept all that
information compartmentalized within
those people they didn't tell them
anything extra that they did your deal
was this little widget that's all you
did was that one little bit and yet no
idea what else was right into this
widget right and he mentions that there
was hangers adjacent hangers next to him
like lined up with different crafts and
then they didn't even let them go look
at different different spacecraft and
one of the things he talks about is that
they don't want this getting out mainly
because they don't want another country
to learn about it and try to what use it
like to weaponize it against other
countries so it all comes back to people
just fighting each other for power and
dominance and absolutely look at look at
space force space force has just been
united here in the u.s. they actually
just started drafting people and
drafting people but taking volunteers
into space force I heard stories four or
five years ago that's the the programs
that Reagan put on back in the early 80s
which were supposed to be the system
that was set up there to knock out other
nuclear devices that were launched at
you through space and instead these guys
were dropping titanium rods out of
vehicles that were up in space and when
you take a titanium rod and you drop it
through space and it comes in supersonic
speed the damage that it does there's no
explosion there's no explosion it looks
like somebody under the earth pushed up
a big breath of air yeah but it's
unbelievable so if you go back to the
80s and we were doing that I still think
they're doing that today when you look
at a lot of these flights they're coming
out of NASA with these new rockets are
launching up I think they're sending up
titanium rods mm-hmm and I think they
keep these things fed they can send
these things anywhere within 30 minutes
we no longer have missile silos anymore
this all the s-- missile silos have been
decommissioned yeah why we have better
means now we can be anywhere you can't
hide deep enough from a titanium rod
coming in out of space and they went to
titanium rods it's the same thing they
used with Abrams tanks they don't use
the explosive device
they shoot with actually a titanium rod
comes out who who is actually using
those rods the u.s. is right now with
the Abrams tanks Oh use those on this
today and it has it's out in titanium
rod titanium run has a full-of-shit
flechette goes on both sides of it to
fill the actually fill the barrel level
this titanium rod in the center of it
and it's that is the rocket or as the
flechette is shut out the front they
peel away and just this titanium rod
comes out the front where does it come
from space no it's actually this is on
the tanks the Abrams tanks that are here
now I shoot them on the ground so when
you shoot another tank all you want to
do is kill the guys aside so this
titanium rod will Pierce right through
that skin and go inside and kill all the
guys aside Jesus very little explosion
other than you know if you have a
cook-off of explosive because you've got
all the charges inside the tank and
those things get hit they'll go off but
there's no explosion and so when they
started realizing that the the
capability of a titanium rod shot at
these unbelievable speeds they see Wow
look at the danger look at the damage
that's done and there's no real
explosion there's no pressure does that
work what it's just it's just ass
exactly you're coming in at supersonic
speeds so if what the the guy that
showed me these originally on youtube
they were called tunnel bombs and he
goes I said so why are they call him
tunnel bombs he does we didn't know what
else to call them we didn't they were
this was these guys were supposed to be
dropping these in Syria you know the war
was kind of going on yeah it kind of
gotten real crazy and this guy was he
was definitely the CIA and he was
telling me how they were dropping these
titanium rods like Micheline looked at
it like you know what part of the CIA
are you actually with so and dave was
able Dave had the authority to move
satellites so he's a pretty reliable
source and then when he showed me the
videos I might dude that's pretty
impressive it would literally take out a
whole block of this city with no
explosion no explosion Wow
he goes you can't hide deep enough you
can
get into a mountain deep enough that we
can't come get you we can be anywhere
with these things in 30 minutes
yeah so now again conspiracy people talk
about it people don't talk about it is
it real you know when you talk about the
astronauts and they see alien beings on
the moon or they talk about through
project disclosure one of the guys
that's in project disclosure was a navy
photographer he got picked up and had
matter of fact he had a security
clearance that I actually if I would
have saw these people sitting with him
and he's talked about the security
clearance he had I thought it was a joke
because I'd never heard of it but he got
pulled into a room and he said that I
just literally just started and he goes
I thought my job primarily was to look
at satellite footage and kind of make a
determination as to what the building we
were looking at what that building did
and he goes the guy that was in the in
the room while I was there said hey come
check this out these are buildings on
the Dark Side of the Moon
and he said I was like what and he goes
yeah check these these are buildings and
ducks are there and they're not ours
so you take a moment you step back and
you go wait a minute but these aren't
just regular people this isn't just a
regular guy he's here with matter of
fact the official that was with this
group also was he sat on a government
board out of Canada and when they
brought him to the forefront he was the
first politician of real authority that
came out and said UFOs are as real as
the planes that fly over your house the
US has been dealing with a group called
the tall whites for the last 15 years
and then he went down this this whole
thing and you're like wait a minute tall
whites what the hell is that
the other guy came out and said we're
we've been in touch with 56 different
races of alien beings holy these again
just aren't regular guys these are guys
with tremendous backgrounds that come
from security clearance and dia and NSA
officials that are all part of project
disclosure and they wanted to come out
they were actually telling Congress hey
we want you to come out now and put this
big meeting on so these guys come out
but the problem is if you come out too
quick and you are being on the payroll
because you're retired military guy
we're gonna come arrest you now you've
just given up secrets or we don't want
to confirm that what you were saying is
true but we're gonna go and screw around
with your pay now so now you're not
gonna get paid we're gonna create this
problem so a lot of these guys were
really sticking it way out there if you
had a project disclosure you go to the
website look at yeah
like I say Greer is up is a great guys
factual Steven Greer yeah what I like is
you know as a doctor and he even comes
out talks about this he goes as a as a
doctor and my buddy here's an a lawyer
he goes were under oath we can't lie if
I lie I could lose my license the
website is serious disclosure com si RI
us highly recommend disclosure calm
again dealing with educated men who come
from great backgrounds from the military
from science professionals from the
airline's industry and when you hear the
stories you're gonna scratch your head
you're gonna be like what it sounds so
unbelievable but yet these guys have no
reason to lie the whole idea what's
about project disclosure and getting the
information out to the American people
so doing so becomes a challenge in
itself because everything just sounds
crazy you would think if the government
was gonna sort of let this stuff out of
the bag they will definitely want to do
it all at once they would do it slowly
they would slowly let it let the drip
you know I mean like I would say the
Pentagon would declassify the videos
then they would slowly sort of release
more things so people just didn't in it
and if you look to they think the CIA
just released 13 million pages so this
information is being leaked now you know
here we are having this conversation
about it yeah so you when you start to
take into consideration you know again
who knows about Brazil right now I mean
I haven't heard anybody really talk
about it one way or the other it's
amazing to me that nobody has really
talked about it